One of them won ÇMelodi Grand PrixÈ and the other won ÇMelodifestivalenÈ.
Please welcome Alexander Rybak and Benjamin Ingrosso!
Benjamin, do you remember ...
... where you were when he won the international final last time?
Yeah, I actually do!
Don't say that you weren't born!
No!
How old were you?
I had just learnt to speak.
No, I'm joking.
Let's see. It was around ten years ago, right?
Nine.
I was 11. 10-11 years old.
I was actually at Carola's house, watching Eurovision Song Contest.
Because ...
So we have ...
... Pernilla Wahlgrens son is sitting at Carola's house, watching the Eurovision Song Contest?
It doesn't become more Eurovision than that?
No! But I'm an old friend of her son's. So we had been watching a movie about Jesus the entire evening, actually.
And eaten macaroni with sausage and ketchup.
Which I as an Italian am a little skeptical about, pasta and ketchup, you know ...
And I remember that I was like ...
ÇWow, that's really good!È
And I ran out in their garden and pretended to be Alexander after that.
ÇI'm in love with a fairytale ...È
I thought it was a great song!
Thank you!
Alexander, how would you say that that success changed you?
... and your personality?
Me or my personality?
Your personality!
It's really easy to lose yourself in the middle of all this.
How did it happen?
Well, it ...
For instance ...
For instance, a friend of mine asked if we should do a football evening.
And I replied: ÇFootball evening?! Did you not see what happened in Eurovision?!È
ÇI don't have time for ...È
So, you say stupid things.
So I think you are ...
... more prepared, actually. You're 20?
20, yes.
You seem professional, and you have both your head and your heart in the right place.
There's something about ... You have this in common, the two of you ... That you ...
You've been somewhat wonder children.
And stars since you were quite young.
And you did musicals and were doing stuff at a very young age.
Yes, exactly.
Who were you in school?
In school? Wow. I was quite different in school.
I wasn't the smartest in class, and ...
I loved everything that didn't have anything to do with school.
I had different periods of being different roles when I was a kid.
I was never myself. I was ÇVanhedenÈ in ÇJšnssonliganÈ for half a year.
Yes, I've also been him!
Short trousers and loafers!
That's ÇOlsenbandenÈ!
What did you say?
ÇJšnssonligan.È
ÇOlsenbandenÈ in Norwegian.
We're gonna talk about those later.
Anyways, so then I dressed up as ÇVanhedenÈ with a hat.
And I was him. I went into character.
And I was James Bond for a while.
And then I was John Travolta. I dyed my hair black and wrote in a black dot on my chin.
So in all my class photos ...
Were you very popular, or ..?
No, no, no, I had no friends.
And the problem was that the teachers weren't the nicest either, because they ...
They ...
Because I seldom understood when we had math and subjects like that ...
... I would try to tell them that I didn't understand, but they always thought that I was playing dumb.
So it ended up with me being that ...
... strange kid who is just weird.
But when you wanted to entertain and be funny, did no one want to be in the audience thern, or ..?
So I went to a very fancy school in …stermalm in Stockholm, and ...
... in that school, it's not cool with culture and stuff like that.
I didn't fit in from the beginning.
It was the same school as our princess Victoria went to.
There's not a lot of ÇVanhedenÈ there.
No, there were no ÇVanhedenÈs there at all.
How strict was it for you when it comes to discipline?
I come from a country, Belarus, where there is a lot of discipline.
In Belarus, you learn to write and read when you're three.
But my parents mixed this discipline with a lot of cleverness and love.
So they ...
How did they get you to practice?
They were quite smart. When I realised that the other children didn't ...
... have to practice two hours very day after school ...
They said: ÇBut if continue, you'll get this big set of LegosÈ and  things like that.
They were very smart, because I then felt like I had something ...
... to reach for, always.
And it was great.
But I felt different. And I think that children in school will feel like that no matter what.
But I remember coming home crying to my dad ...
And I said: ÇDad, I'm doing something completely different from everyone else, and they don't understand me.È
And he said to me:
ÇAs people, we're just generally scared of everything that's different.È
ÇWe're scared of things that are different.È
ÇAnd you have to believe in yourself, and believe in the things that are different about you. And if you believe in that ...È
ÇThe others will also believe that after a while.È
And that was so important for me to hear, from my dad.
Were you also different as a child?
Yes. I was also ÇVanhedenÈ, but I also changed between him and ÇDynamit-HarryÈ quite a lot.
And ÇPapphammarÈ!
But I guess I was quite ...
I also played a lot of roles. I was quite ...
... overweight as a child.
... and so my way of being included, was to be funny.
... at my own expense.
So, I would be funny about myself before anyone had the chance to tease me.
I had to be funny first, simply.
And that was a hard school to be a part of.
Humour-wise.
And then you have to recapture yourself, to sort of ...
... feel like you're not selling yourself short. But it was ...
... exactly the same ...
ÇVanhedenÈ is grateful to work with.
You were ...
You mentioned your Russian background, and you're half Italian ...
Ingrosso.
Yes.
You still live at home?
Yes, I live at home.
So you're living this teenage life?
Yes, I am! But I cook the food at home, so I'm responsible for that.
Thanks, thanks!
Do you still have posters in your room?
If I've had posters in my room?
Yeah, do you still have your teenage posters there?
Yes.
My songwriting colleagues were at my place once, and we were going to eat dinner and ...
They were completely shocked when they entered my room, because the hadn't thought about that I was ...
19-20 years old.
So when they came into my room, they were like ...
ÇEh. Benjamin, you're 12.È
I still have my stuff from when I was younger.
I have to have, like ...
A Batman doll up on my shelf and things like that.
And a ÇJšnssonliganÈ poster.
But I like it. I think it's ...
I think it's nice.
Did you have any posters on the wall?
I've still got my old bedroom back at my parent's house.
And there I've got all the ... I had more ...
... pictures of beautiful women, really.
Jennifer Love Hewitt ...
What's her name? Angelina Jolie.
Pernilla Wahlgren, people like that.
His mom!
Who did you have?
I'm thinking the same, who did I have?
I was really bohemian. I had road signs that I had found and things like that.
And tall hats and old ladders.
And I think I had Michael Bolton!
Exactly when he started to become bald up there.
I also had Twisted Sisters.
Wow. Good!
You've got a good range with Twisted Sister and Michael Bolton, you're an open person?
Yeah, just like that. I'm a mix of those two.
You're on your way to Lisbon, you're going to compete against each other.
And this is ...
Is this the first time you're performing outside Sweden?
Abroad?
Yes.
Yes. Professionally, yes. Absolutely.
What do you mean? Have you performed privately?
Uhm.
I don't know if you can call this performing abroad, but this one time we were in the Canary Islands when I was around nine years old.
With my family.
That counts!
Yes, that counts!
And my mom was having a gig at this ...
... Italian restaurant three nights in a row. And it was her together with this Elvis impersonator.
And I ...
... had just started my Elvis period.
So I was walking around in Elvis clothes in the Canary Islands.
And I asked: ÇExcuse me. Mom, do you think I can go up there and be Elvis with Elvis?È
And she said that I should ask him.
So I asked him before the show, being around eight years old, and he was like: ÇYes, absolutely!È
And he was like ÇDo you know how?È, and I was like: ÇYes, I can do thisÈ.
So when I got up there, people started coming over from other restaurants, and in the end it was packed. And I did my Elvis thing.
So the night after I got to do it again.
And then I was one of the artists!
That was my first ...
... gig abroad, you could say!
I've actually also performed in the Canary Islands!
But I was the back side of a donkey. I was a horse's ass.
In something called ÇMiniklubbenÈ.
I wasn't asked back the night after.
You didn't to a good enough job?
I was inside the ass.
There was one person in the front and one in the back. I was in the back, wagging the tail.
You weren't good enough, since they didn't let you back?
We only did it one night.
It was one night only?
Once upon a time ...
Yeah, because that has to be ...
... the biggest compliment you could get, is when you're ...
... asked to do it again.
We've got ...
Before we continue the show, the two of you are gonna do a small ...
A small medley, I think?
I don't know more than that you've asked to get some ...
We found out that ...
Sorry, I just interrupted you ...
But we found out that ...
... our songs are in the same key.
And they've almost got a similar vibe in the chords, so ...
So we've found each other in the music!
So Norway and Sweden are competing in Lisbon in the same key?
Exactly!
Is that a problem?
No! It's 2018, baby!
Let's get Benjamin's guitar in here!
Okay, shit.
So we ... Should we just ...
It's fun that they're in the same key and that they're a little the same ...
Let's see if they still are!
I'll try to not sing falsetto this time, then.
Fun!
You'll meet again in Lisbon May 12th!
Thanks so much for being here tonight!